mais juste avant on va parler de meghan
markle meghan markle capricieuse ou
manipulatrice a pas une semaine sans
qu'une nouvelle info suresnes en général
sont plutôt négatives
ainsi par exemple mattias therman à la
pub me disais c'est juste une actrice
ratée ambitieuse qu'en pensent certains
résumé d'abord danse magnéto et puis
ensuite on pourra débattre regardez
c'est le conte de fées du 21e siècle
telle cendrillon la jeune libet
l'américaine meghan markle trouve
l'amour anglais royal dans les bras du
prince harry se regardent façon show
breizh ça se donne la main sur la plage
à s'échangent des pulls en peau de yack
et ça s'embrasse au calme après une
petite partie de power sauf que voilà
derrière ce visage d'ange se cacherait
un véritable démon accès de colère
brouille avec quelques comportements de
divas entorse au protocole bref la
totale
une mégane tyrannie copeaux de faire
démissionner son assistante la française
mélissa toi petit au bout de seulement
six mois pourtant très apprécié à
buckingham
mélissa aurait craqué suite aux caprices
de la princesse comme le révèle un
proche au daily mail
c'était devenu trop dur à la fin elle a
dû supporter beaucoup de choses mais
gagne lui réclamer beaucoup et ça s'est
terminé en larmes quand on sait que la
française a pourtant collaborer avec le
chaud bouillant robbie williams sans le
moindre pépin ça en dit long sur le
caractère de l'américaine en ajoutant
samantha cohen autre assistante royal en
place depuis 20 ans qui envisageraient
aussi de partir bonjour l'ambiance au
château alors face à toutes ces
révélations qui écorne la prestation
jusque là sans faute de megan le prince
furax harry vient de contre attaquer
avec le lancement de l'opération chasse
à la taupe dans les galeries du palais
alors mégane ange ou démon
je veux dénoncer il ya plusieurs démos
quand même sur ce plateau évidemment on
aura votre réponse chez vous aussi
myriam donc ange ou démon l'avion de
sujets ça y va c'est laval assistante
qui dégage les dénoncer c'est quelqu'un
qui voit là comme le disait mathieu tout
à l'heure plutôt quelqu'un d'arrivistes
nous on a essayé de contacter en fait
son assistante française qui a été ce
réfugié lui sont odieuses voilà dans la
région lyonnaise et qui est totalement
flipper et qui refuse de parler elle a
été fatale est vraiment très
insupportable et très incorrectes avec
son personnel et d'ailleurs c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles elle s'est
elle s'est disputée avec kate parce que
lorsqu'elle a été invitée à noël l'année
dernière pour pour pour un dîner elle a
extrêmement mal parlé aux assistantes de
kate et du coup ça s'est très très mal
passé alors vous n'avez pas réussi à la
joindre mais elle a quand même parlé à
ses passions verra la station dans le
bar cosy et marqué à l'adie son poste
était soumis à une très intense pression
elle parle de mégane et au final c'en
était trop à l'aide du supporter
beaucoup de choses mais gagnera monde et
beaucoup beaucoup trop des prochains
elle a pas refusé alors les ailes à elle
a une clause de confidentialité voilà
très très sévère qui l'empêchent de
parler mais le signe de son départ et
quand même quelque chose d'important
parce que personne ne lâche un poste
pareil dont c'est la première fois que
comme ça d'entendre c'est pas le genre
de fausses qu'on lâche donc ça ça veut
dire qu'il reste quand même quelque
chose alors guillaume avant d'avoir à
part parce que le roi guillaume qui est
la nôtre stéphane bern qui s'énerve
nature vous avez très virulent vous
pourquoi chiffres l'an passé mais
forcément qu'elle est ingérable ça fait
dix ans qu'elle essayait d'être actrice
ça ne marchait pas donc il un sentiment
de revanche envers les gens qui
l'entourent aujourd'hui vous savez c'est
le contraire de grace kelly grace kelly
qui était la plus grande actrice du moon
qui a épousé le prince de monaco qui
était une femme remarquable déjà vu un
papier qu'on allait parce que simplement
il n'y est pas
tim en revanche n'est pas un complexe il
avait mûri pendant des années elle a
galéré pendant des années des années ça
marchait pas à la rive balle on voit
tout moi c'est pas vrai ce que tu dis
parce que meghan markle justement a été
actrice et elle a au moins le mérite de
rester elle même studio elle arrive dans
ce ballet où il faut tout est policé
faut se tenir bien faire la révérence
tout ça elle amène cette fraîcheur là ne
pas rester ne pas devenir contenir de
yom ha ben c'est bien fauteuil et
baissez vous les bonnes questions ces
photos ne tient pas bah oui pas de
plafond de ce oui pardon et c'est vrai
que et que du coup alors elle s'entend
pas inquiète parce que kate est vraiment
le modèle de la fille parfaite qu'il
faut rester tous à l aller dans un truc
beaucoup plus rock quelques pas mais
c'est mieux qu'elle arrive à rester un
peu à elle même et qu elle dépoussière
ce truc là quand même
moi je donne pas mon avis mais j'étais
calme l'un des premiers en france n'a
des premiers en france à le dire je la
sens pas je la sens vous savez pas ce
que vous avez le goût du sang ou de la
vérité on n'est pas le jeu la foire dans
un instant c'est à dire à la fin
d'émission
katrina mot pour vous des monts aussi
nous sert pas vraiment parce
qu'effectivement au début il ya des
rumeurs après il ya des faits la
démission de sept personnes
un collaborateur du prince harry qui a
démissionné ce qui est plus triste dans
cette histoire c'est que lui qui est
réputé pour être un garçon c'est
sympathique jovial drôle et charmant ça
détend son caractère il devient un peu
agressif un petit peu virulent et ça va
ça crée une mauvaise ambiance et je
pense qu'en effet moi je t'ai accord
avec toi il ya c'est le syndrome de la
cnsa par là guillaume guillaume cela sur
les séries deux minutes y'a quand même
des faits c'est ce que dit catherine à
la raison il ya ce qu'on peut croire la
presse people un sentiment qu'on peut
avoir comme moi quand je connais pas
bien le dossier
mais il ya des faits coco et non c4
alors oui à tout pour elle pas les cons
alors oui c'est une américaine qui
arrive dans une institution qui a mille
cinq cents ans où rien n'a changé depuis
300 ans
alors évidemment kate middleton elle est
un peu ennuyeuse
elle est un peu chiante il faut le dire
avec william ils sont terriblement petit
bourgeois ils sont tristes houllier et
compagnie sur ça ils font rêver personne
le petit harry il est en effet il
devient un peu irascible parce que il ne
veut pas que il arrive à megan ce qui
est arrivé à sa mère serre que la presse
entière s'amuse à dire que sa femme est
une harpie une [ __ ]
elle est horrible et vachin non pas du
tout elle c'est une super active qui
celle qui se lève tôt alors oui en effet
il ya eu deux collaborateurs qui sont
partis mais 3 me en avait beaucoup
c'est sur 150 en un an dans l'appareil
mais non c'est donc en avant ça il reste
encore 2 2 c'est exactement pareil à
l'époque on voulait absolument opposé
sarah ferguson et diana aujourd'hui eh
ben on y est encore
on oppose kate et mégane vous savez la
singularité de la famille britannique
never explain never compliance en
dessous dernièrement et dernier si
sébastien finir sington a dit c'est
terminé il n'y a pas de problème tout ça
est du pipeau c'est inventer ou plus en
une phrase ce hacker reste plus qu'une
minute daniel moi j y avait quand même
mais vous avez raison mathieu quand vous
dites que vous sentiez mal vous l ai pas
du tout princesse son premier mari elle
a quand même renvoyé sa bague de
fiançailles et l'alliance par courrier
c'est comme ça qu'il a appelé des démons
bah non mais franchement ça c'est alors
la laisse aux dernières nouvelles en
fait elle elle a annoncé qu'elle allait
travailler à faire de la représentation
jusqu'au dernier moment ce qui embête un
petit peu le alors ouais enfin le voilà
parce que ça va brouiller un petit peu
le travail de kate sur les enfants
défavorisés
donc il ya quand même et kate a pris le
look de megan notre jour mais elle
essayait belle essaye de courir derrière
mégane et les coûts vraiment 4-5-1 des
trésors tard qu'un second de sa poule et
des rameaux savez bruit juste quand tu
es rumeurs deviennent insistant
tassement lifeway les prendre au sérieux
jamais depuis mars il y aura marqué dans
mon boulot régulièrement balancer des
rumeurs et des gens disaient non c'est
n'importe quoi quand ça devient
assistant et qu'on va les vérifier on se
rend compte que c'est vrai donc moi je
dis que là j'aime bien conclure et
dessus ce que j'aime bien pour crytek
mon avis le sondage vous qu'est ce que
vous en pensez en joue démons merde
annonce à 55% pour vous mais peut-être
que ça changera après les gens voter
pendant parce qu'on la zac m éclairer
sur mes joues dit à mon avis je le sens
pas cette histoire là